happy no not november reject nation we
got ourselves a book of boba fett
trailer making the challenge for
november a real challenge indeed now
before we go into this got a little
story to tell got word yesterday this
trip might come out john let's check our
phones at 6 00 am checked our phones at
6 00 am nothing came out said john says
for another hour i said
i checked nothing i went back to sleep
because i'm a fool john checked got it
hit the road fought through traffic kill
the family on the way over here just to
be here and then by the time i woke up
john was coming up the stairs john was
on top of it today
you know i've been waiting for this day
it feels good asset to the company i
just want to thank everyone involved
with boba fett robert rodriguez john
favreau everyone uh for making this
moment possible and it's all downhill
from here
my padawan
[Music]
i am not a bounty hunter
[Music]
said the most famous bounty hunter
i'm not a monster
we see that yeah
that chipped bob paint i know that you
sit on the throne of your former
employer
[Music]
i intend to rule with
respect smaller spot
you're always captains under job of the
hut
i'm here to make a proposal that's
mutually beneficial
he's already got two great lives in this
trip
why speak of conflict
when cooperation can make us all rich
this prevents us all from killing you
and taking what we want
[Music]
if he had spoken such insolence to jabba
he'd have fed you to his menagerie
please
speak freely
was am i this crazy or was every lady
said badass
yep pretty much
they're like that's the one writing tip
for the season is like everything boba
says has to be a few words and the most
badass it could possibly be tamora
morrison has that capability of being
able to just take a line of dialogue and
and make it a quote based off of his
delivery alone so he's really just
trying to become an actual like gangster
leader
in the galaxy he's trying to put the
bounty hunter life behind him and show
that he's more than that he wants to
earn his way through respect and not be
the job of the hut way i mean you got to
be a little bit intimidating but he
wants to be an actual like leader in
this field it's kind of like watching a
godfather story like the godfather of
freaking star wars it's kind of
impressive
you're just watching it or like scarface
you know
we'll end with a mountain of cocaine and
fennec trying to make it
but it's a tough position for where this
guy is at because as we saw at the if
i'm not mistaken from that post credit
scene it was before tuna who was in the
the throne of the jabba palace and then
taking over jabba who is such a you know
dominant figure in this specific world
of this side of the galaxy i'd imagine a
lot of people will compare the way boba
goes about it to jabba and a lot of
people would probably think as you see
in the trailer here that some people are
probably just going to try to take him
out directly like you don't deserve to
be here why why should we listen to you
why should we work with you you're just
a bounty hunter so it seems like that i
like the line that he has here jabba
rule of fear i'm gonna rule of respect i
think is what he said because it seems
like that's what he's aiming for this
whole time yeah it's just i want to rule
with respect because i have to earn
respect before i was just a work for
hire dude because everyone's gonna be
taunting him the whole time about like
paul and solo knocked me to the store
she says everyone's gonna come over and
try to hit him in the jet pack yeah i
think fly off
oh
yeah careful there you wouldn't want to
hit the door frame fly off buddy but
yeah you got this like power vacuum that
seems like it'll be interesting to watch
him try to fill and timora morrison just
has that interesting blend of yeah you
can tell this is a man of honor even
though he's not afraid to get his hands
dirty whatsoever true ass son i love the
idea of him you know in this new
republic era taking advantage almost of
yeah the fall of the empire to kind of
set up something and take i don't know
if it's really like taking back what's
rightfully his but yeah like filling
a void for you know the people of
tattooing at the very least and uh just
like the this just looks so beautiful in
the array of you know familiar
characters and settings but also just
the way this looks like it'll become
kind of a political western of sorts
definitely you know that's definitely
more that what i imagine robert
rodriguez when taking [ __ ] seriously
would do yeah
yeah with some collaborators with whom
he has to kind of keep in line yeah well
it seems like the story of boba fett is
coming a little full circle here because
when you go back to
his experiences as a child in clone wars
i think her name with the gang he got
involved with was aura singh i want to
say is her name i've only seen it once
i'm sorry or a singer must say he would
just get involved with the you know the
wrong crowds yeah over time and but
beyond just being a a boy who would
eventually become a bounty hunter who
fell into the sarlacc pit he's had his
experiences navigating the criminal
underworld or the the the underbelly of
bellies
navigating the criminal underworld all
this time and to me this feels like it
is a completion of the boba fett story
of a guy who was born a clone but raised
as the son of jango fett and then got
involved with gangs and such when you
see jango fett he's working for the cam
and owen so he's he's like much higher
up he's not just like a dude working
amongst other like thugs and criminals
yeah and then to come here it seems like
a full journey for boba fett and i
imagine it's more than mobison tomorrow
morbius
tomorrow
morrison is having just the time of his
life right now man yeah absolutely it's
the timurassance or something like that
because yeah this is a character who has
seen kind of every level of the criminal
worlds of star wars it seems like and so
he would be kind of suited to bring yeah
that you know humanity experience with
you know being the son of django fed and
yeah not necessarily being as inclined
towards being a full-on criminal but
also being able to easily navigate that
what's cool about this trailer that i
think is capturing really well is
between like him and fennick just that
sexual cancer no not about it
november
but i think it's capturing really well
especially when at first if you were to
look at images you would be like oh this
takes place in the star wars the
mandalorian world right just based off
of the aesthetic and who's involved yada
yada yada the mandalorian has a little
bit of its own special look to it that
that's distinguishes itself from the
star wars movies this though you can
tell is going to be way more gritty
and you can feel a little bit more of a
grounded
i don't know that's not the right word
for a star wars you know something
that's a little bit more
near yeah what i want to do to describe
it is just clench my teeth yeah there's
something that's kind of nitty gritty
about it that looks maybe a little more
again if you're dealing directly
mandalorian you got bounty hunter and
all that stuff but this looks like it's
more directly in the world of the
criminals yeah you know and having to
navigate the moral gray areas of that
and having to watch out because
everyone's probably a cutthroat few
people you can trust and i love the bond
it looks like that's formed between boba
and fennec and i'm excited too to see
what kind of flashbacks they mix in
because i have to imagine they're going
to do some explaining on how he survived
the sarlacc pit and other things like oh
and the starlock craps them out
yeah yeah i can't wait for that extended
butthole sequence all right guys thank
you so much for being here john
you did well my boy
thanks
oh my mini chlorians are going crazy
right now yeah
what are those guys subscribe to real
rejects click that notification bell hit
that like button we will be covering the
show on the channel so you know you know
what to do check us out on patreon
johnny did such a good job
why don't you go edit down these 13
minutes of footage and get it up in 10
minutes you better